-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
We're here with D'Arcy Carden.
Um, you know, wonderful cast.
Big cast, famous names.
-I just did the thing
that people do on talk shows
where I saw myself in the --
I kind of -- I saw myself
and I adjusted.
[ Laughter ]
Like, I'm talking to you,
but I'm like -- Oh. Oh.
-And you know what the funny
thing is?
Everybody watching
could see it.
You know what I mean?
Like, I do it, too.
-Yes.
-Where you think you're catching
yourself in a mirror,
but you forget it's the thing
everyone sees.
-Yes, totally. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-TV, baby.
-[ Laughs ]
-You were saying?
-And you think,
"I'll do it really subtly."
-Yeah, nobody will notice
that I'm, like,
sort of looking like this.
And...okay, anyway.
You were saying, sir?
-What's it like --
Jennifer Lopez, Lenny Kravitz.
Who else is in the film?
-Oh, my God.
-What's it like,
that first table read
when you sit down with
those sort of A-list names?
-So, I mean, the cast is insane
because it's Lenny Kravitz
and it's J.Lo and Sonia Braga,
and it's all these people that
are -- [stammers]
The table read was insane.
But the funny thing is,
the only thing I can think of
when I think of the table read
is that is when I met J.Lo.
-Yeah.
-Okay. That's Jennifer Lopez.
[ Laughter ]
-I -- It was
this big old table read.
I see her come in. You can,
like, feel it when she walks
into the room.
I can see her come in,
and all of a sudden, I was like,
"Okay, this is going to be
a long table read. I got to --
I got to pee.
I gotta go pee.
I gotta to run and go pee.
-Yep, very smart.
-I can't -- Thank you.
-Yeah.
-And that's part of the biz.
-That's why you're good
at the biz.
-Exactly. Yeah.
-Yeah.
So I ran to go pee,
and I open the bathroom door,
and immediately I'm like,
"Something is up."
And I open the stall
and it's just not good.
-Okay.
-It's bad in there. It's bad.
-Someone left it
not the way they found it.
-It shouldn't have -- Yes.
Yeah, exactly.
It's so bad that I, like,
have to wash my hands
just being in the room.
Yes.
-You saw it and had
to wash your hands.
-I saw it and was like,
"I got to go. I got to go."
I'm washing my hands to leave
and who walks in the door --
[ Audience groans and laughs ]
-Oh, no. Yeah.
Can I call her J.Lo?
Can I say J.Lo?
-Yes, you can. Yeah.
-My guess is J.Lo.
-She did, yeah.
-Yeah.
-So she walks in the door.
I'm washing my hands,
which is just admitting guilt.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so I, like, run out, and
I run into her security guard,
and I just go,
"It's bad in there."
[ Laughter ]
-Good. Good cover.
-Yeah, I don't know.
-And then later you, like,
tried to laugh and cover.
Be like, "I bet you probably had
to wash your hands
when you saw it,
because that's what I did."
I washed -- I saw it and...
-I saw it and washed.
-...Washed my hands,
in case you're wondering why.
-I just said that
to everybody near her
so that she maybe overheard.
Lenny is like, "Why are you
telling me this again?"
[ Laughter ]
-There's a scene where
all this incredible cast
is shooting in a swimming pool
fully clothed.
-Yes.
-And I don't want to give
anything away from the plot,
but you're forced to be
in the swimming pool
fully clothed.
I would imagine
that is not good times?
[ Laughter ]
-It's funny, because we're in
the Dominican Republic.
It's so beautiful.
We're shooting in this gorgeous
pool overlooking literally,
like, whales jumping
out of the ocean.
It was so, like, idyllic --
is that how you say it?
-Yeah.
-Idyllic? It was so beautiful.
But we were in the pool
for, like, 20 days.
We were shooting in the pool
for three weeks.
-That's too many days.
What you'll find is three
is too many days.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Your skin starts reacting
weird. We had, like,
rashes, like the --
you know, I don't know, maybe
the filter stopped working
at some point.
There's just, like, sunscreen.
So to complain about it is so
silly because it really was
just such a joy, but it was --
our skin -- it was soggy.
It was very soggy.
-Yeah.
-It was funny to see, like,
Cheech and Lenny,
who are wearing full, like,
suits, you know,
like wedding-y attire.
They -- We'd all be in the water
up to our necks,
and then they'd be like,
"Okay, that's lunch."
And just like --
[ Blows raspberries ]
[ Laughter ]
Just, like, trudging out of
the swimming pool,
like, eating their chicken
in soaking wet clothes.
Because you could change
into your robe,
but then what are you going
to do?
Put on your wet suit again?
-That's even worse, right.
-Worse!
-Just tough it out.
Stay in the wet suit.
-Tough it out, yeah.
-Now, the idea of seeing
Lenny Kravitz of all people,
who -- cool emanates off
this man.
-He like, defines it.
-And to be in a wet suit
eating chicken, that seems --
-I know.
-Like, this should not happen
to a man at his level.
-You, like, have to avert
your eyes.
-Yeah.
-But did you enjoy your time
with Lenny?
-I did.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, he's great.
-Yeah, and you lived with him.
-We lived together. It was
like -- I mean, he is --
he is just a rockstar.
-By the way, when his wife
was living with Lenny Kravitz,
I hope Henry Winkler
called up Jason and said,
"You can come stay with us."
[ Laughter ]
"I know this must be a very hard
time for you right now."
-It's the same thing.
It's exactly the same thing.
"You're going through a thing.
Come stay with us.
Clean your teeth."
-[ Laughs ]
-Yeah, it was great.
He just is -- it was such
a weird thing,
living with Lenny Kravitz.
Like, you would be
eating breakfast
and he would come to
the breakfast table in, like,
a shirt that was open to here
and, like, leather pants.
-Yeah.
-But we were there for months.
So we really -- Everybody --
I know casts always say
we became a family,
but we really did.
-[ Laughs ]
-We really did.
-Yeah. The other people
are posers, but you guys --
-And I've said it before.
-Yeah, and not meant it.
-But you know, it was, like,
a year into COVID.
I had had no meals with anybody
other than Jason.
There it is.
I finally said his name.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-My husband.
-We got it out there.
-Yeah.
-I had not made a new friend.
You remember that time.
-Yeah.
-It was dark.
And so to have all the --
I don't know.
It was such a bonding
experience.
It was so -- and to live
with each other on top of it
was just, like, insane.
It was so great.
-Well, that's really fun.
Congratulations on the film.
It's always so lovely
to have you here.
-I love ya.
-Thank you so much.
You guys, that's D'Arcy Carden.
"Shotgun Wedding" is streaming
now on Prime Video.
We'll be back
with more "Late Night."